can you hear them the drums so
interesting piece of news about Peter
Capaldi's last episode it's going to be
the I pretty sure the Christmas special
for this year where he regenerates into
whoever they end up casting later and
that is it's going to see the return of
John Simm as the master now I will admit
that when I first read that headline my
immediate reaction was mmm
cuz I thought have we gotten around to
doing my ranking of the Masters I need
to I really need to do that soon but
Johnson not my favorite he was much
better in his second appearance when
they brought him back but certainly that
first one really didn't care for him so
the idea of him coming back initially I
was kind of like not thrilled but then
it was made pretty explicitly clear that
both he and Missy are going to be
appearing and that kind of struck my
interest and then when I actually
stopped and thought it I was like wait a
minute they've never done the multiple
masters story before I mean we've been
getting multiple doctors stories since
the 70s but we've never had a multiple
masters story I think larger that just
has to do with the fact that it wasn't
really an option I mean the original
master Roger Delgado he died in a car
accident and then you know they had a
couple of interim guys and really heavy
makeup and then it was Anthony Ainley
for a very long time
and by the time the new series got going
he had passed away and I don't think was
ever on the table to bring Eric Roberts
back to cameo as the master again so I
just I'm not sure it was ever actually
possible to do before and now they can
and when I put it in that context yeah
I'm interested in I'm intrigued by that
I'm hoping that sin coming back that his
master is going to be more in line with
his second appearance than with his
first and obviously circumstances are
going to determine that because what I'd
like to watch more about his second
appearance was that he was more unhinged
she was more unpredictable and he just
seemed a bit more dangerous he Steve was
he was
cartoonish he was a bit goofy was a bit
too arch and silly for me and his
initial appearance but he had a more
legitimate edge in that second
appearance and I'm hoping that's more
the flavor ambassador we get and I
really be interested to see that playing
it off against Missy who is also very
unpredictable but has a feeling that is
she feels much more calculating than sim
did especially again especially in that
second appearance where I preferred him
where he was always scheming but he kind
of felt like he was coming up with a
plan as he went along again referring
mainly to that second appearance Missy
you always feel like she's planning
something I don't know what it is but
bad so I'll be really curious to see how
they play off each other I'll be curious
to see do they work well together are
they going to argue with each other I
hope that's not something that's done
too heavily because I think that that's
an easy trap to fall into since you know
we always have the doctors and the
doctors when they work together they you
know maybe they they butt heads a little
bit but they come together and they're
better together they do great things and
when it's the master he'll just fight
with himself like I don't I don't just
want them to do that that seems like the
cop-out way but I would love to see Jo
just little arguments little clashes but
to see the to see the combined threat of
these two I'll be really curious to see
that and part of me wonders if they'll
somehow complement that this is only
occurring to me as I'm saying if they'll
complement that by having Peter Capaldi
for a brief period of the episode shared
the screen with whoever the next doctor
is I'm you know through love the love
the lateness of wibbly-wobbly
timey-wimey meanness um I'm not actually
predicting that will happen but the
thought just occurred to me I thought
I'd share it I don't know maybe and of
course at this point we still don't know
anything about who the next doctor is
going to be I'm not throwing my head
into that speculation because basically
people people just toss out names and
and you know they've got the the
bookkeepers like oh we did four to one
chances that it is bull it's always bull
and more the
weii I want somebody that I don't know
and when I say me I'm not sure I'm not
like be in my bubble I mean speaking as
somebody who enjoys and partakes of
British entertainment I don't want a big
name I want somebody who maybe I can dig
into something's on the path but who I'm
going to go oh okay
who's that I want to be surprised I
don't want a lot of built-in
expectations which is a big part of why
I never get into the speculations
because people are always picking people
who I have done a doctor's role before
like after fantastic beasts and where to
find them came out everyone was I who
ready-made Eddie Redmayne could be the
doctor because his performance was kind
of Matt Smith ish and I'm like well no I
don't I I don't want muse them to just
plug in somebody who you know fits a
template of the doctor that's already
been done give me somebody who I'm not
going to have these dolls and
expectations who has the possibility to
really surprise me and then I'm going
over to complete total tangent from what
I Evert and talking about so could bring
it back what happened
but anyway John Simm coming back initial
reaction was but the more I think about
it the more intrigued I am by it the
more I think it could really be really
potentially interesting and it does kind
of speak to Ivan it seems to be the big
thing right now to just crap on Moffitt
and everything Moffat is done in the
show as a whole I don't have a problem
with Marv with muffets time running the
show there's been upstairs and downs it
was the same with Davies it'll be the
same with Chibnall I'm sure but one
thing that I will say that I wish he had
done is I do wish there had been more
things that originated in the Davies era
that had come back because obviously you
know John Simm will be an example of
that but I would have liked to have seen
you know even was just little things at
the face of BOE again the Jack Harkness
absolutely I just wish there hadn't been
such a clean cut off from one
showrunners era to the next which is
part of why I was upset that
capaldis leaving at the same time as
Moffat I I don't like the feel of these
completely self-contained airs I'd like
I'd like it to feel more free-flowing
I'd like it to feel more like one just
dovetails into the other as opposed to
these kind of harsh cutoff so it feels
like we're getting lately but again not
now I'm tangent Inge yet again I think I
need to go to bed is what I need to do
in any case that's my general thoughts
on Johnson coming back for Peter
Capaldi's final episode I'm out as well
as my random thoughts on a number of
other things so what are your thoughts
are you excited at Johnson coming back
is he one of you one of the Masters you
really like he doesn't make you nervous
that he's coming back how do you think
he's going to play off Capaldi how do
you think he'll play with Missy whatever
your thoughts are on any of it drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter or
council of geeks give us through the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]